do you have any of my knives near you i
don't have any near me i have a knife
near me that
but i don't have any of your knives near
me that you've given me over the years
this is the blade i've been sporting
this uh
it's nice i just like the uh i like the
that is nice two-tone uh not an
expensive knife just got it online
um you should have called me i would
have sent you some
what you're always giving me knives it's
my
it's what i wanted it's my job i know
but the problem is
some of sometimes people find the knives
you give me and they get disturbed
like for christmas you gave me a pair of
brass knuckles
yes they're on my desk and people have
picked them up and they go like what is
this and they go oh those are brass
knuckles
and they think i'm a pimp in my spare
time
so what's the problem not a problem at
all i have now a very good business
that's even now yeah sure
no never now more than ever people long
to be touched when is the last time you
punch someone
uh let's see what's today today's
what's today's yeah be like 1976.
oh a bit a while ago yeah
on the set of uh saturday night fever
no i was not on this um movie star i was
a child then
okay yeah but um
[Music]
that's who'd you punch
she was younger she was much younger
than me oh man
it's about five oh punch from the back
of the head
that's terrible so is it if she's five
and this is 1976 so you're like 33 or
34.
i was in my early 40s you look amazing
thank you i've had a lot of work done